hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the causes
that Aristotle devotes attention to and
distinguishes from other causes in his
metaphysics is what we call the material
cause the cause that is the substrate
the Hoople came and owned in Greek or
the matter the who lay in Greek that
things are made of and in examining the
theories of his predecessors which is a
typical approach for Aristotle he likes
to survey what other people have had to
say about the topic beforehand he's
going to set out and then criticize some
earlier philosophers points of view on
manners because they tried to make
everything all explanation about why
things are the way they are and indeed
what this universe that were in consists
of they tried to make it all depend on a
material cause or material causes some
of them were monists as we call it who
thought everything is really one
fundamental substance or one kind of
stuff and some of them were what we
could call pluralist
by contrast to Mona's who believe there
are many kinds of things that were
irreducible to each other but they all
run into the same basic problems there's
the same inadequacies that are running
throughout their accounts so Aristotle
will talk about a number of different
representative important philosophers
prior to himself and one of them who's
often credited as being sort of like the
you know first real philosopher because
he's saying sort of universal statements
about things his name is Sol Ace and he
was from volantis and he said the rather
counterintuitive thing that everything
is really water now why is that a
metaphysical view because you are
talking about the totality you are
trying to say what everything is made of
and you know you could say to yourself
he must have been nuts how could anybody
possibly think that everything is water
well he had some reasons for that he
looked at the fact that water expands
and contracts and we can see it having
three different forms in our everyday
experience at least if we live in places
that are cold enough for it to freeze
and you know we can heat it up and we
get vapor and we have the liquid and he
also according to Aristotle thought that
the seeds of things were were moist so
that everything living is really in some
way a modification of water and this
fits in with this sort of emphasis on
the material cause they were interested
in in what underlies and persists as
being the principle or cause of things
so in his view it's the water that
actually stays the same
not in its qualities you know it can be
gaseous or it can be frozen it can be
dense it can be rarefied it can be all
different sorts of things but it's still
the same stuff
that everything else would just be
modifications of would be composed of
and that's one possibility another
person not long after that lace and act
some mayonnaise said that no it's not
water instead it's air and then
Aristotle will bring up yet another
pre-socratic thinker Heraclitus of a
thesis who doesn't actually say that
everything is composed of fire but
rather that there's a fire sort of you
know running through everything but
Aristotle takes him as being a monist
who's holding that everything truly is
right now Heraclitus himself so that
everything is in change in flocks so you
know it's it's a little bit more of a
complex theory but we can put that aside
for the moment and then he brings up
empedocles who said while all of those
things are basic elements basic
substance of the universe water air fire
both to them will also add earth and you
put these things together and you can
put them in certain compositions and now
you've got what everything is made of
and the idea behind any one of these
accounts like we just said is that you
have something a material substance that
remains the same throughout all of its
changes and that explains why things are
at all and why they are the way that
they are there were some other thinkers
along those lines that Aristotle also
talks about and here with them pedak
leaves in an exact RIS we're actually
getting to thinkers who are going to
bring in another cause but we're gonna
put that aside for the moment an exec is
in this discussion Plato or Aristotle
points out said that there couldn't be
one single kind of thing nor could there
be a restricted list like say for rather
there had to be
unlimited up here on some people
translate that as infinite but it really
just means without limits
right so whatever whatever number of
basic things there are we can't know
what the number is and these were first
principles so he said you know bone
comes from bone presumably he think iron
comes from iron whatever types of stuff
there is everything comes from what it
is now
the other group that Aristotle talks
about here that kind of fit under this
rubric would be what we call the
atomists and these people believed that
we have matter and matter is composed of
atoms atoms just means the things that
you can't cut any further two main means
to cut and ah means you know Kant or
primitive not and so the atoms are the
basic building blocks of things so you
have atoms and then you have the the
void or the empty tokay known and you
know they identified this as Aristotle
tells us with being and non-being but
they weren't particularly careful about
this and they said that both being and
non-being have being and the upshot of
this for Aristotle is that leucippus and
democritus are not really advancing the
conversation any further they reduced
everything as he says to the shape and
arrangement and position of atoms atoms
are of a certain shape that that
produces certain effects right
arrangements how are the atoms connected
with each other
where are the atoms in relation to other
composites of atoms and that's it that's
that's the extent of their theory as far
as Aristotle is concerned and he
identifies a set of problems with any
account that is going to reduce
everything to a material cause there's
something attractive about it saying
well if we can just get to the
fundamental bill
clocks will know how everything works
but that doesn't get you a full
explanation of things can't account as
he's saying for why the material things
are or become what they are and the way
they are
you can't account for that fully one
thing that he criticizes them for having
ignored although sometimes you know I've
gotten close to figuring out is what we
call the formal cause the essence the
Lucia or the formula the tote ESD the
what it is to be that thing alright and
that's it's not enough to say of the
bronze statue that it's bronze you've
got to account for the form that the
statute has or you're not accounting for
that kind of thing similarly think about
flash right flash by itself is not yet a
human being you might say well you need
bones and veins and all yeah take all
that material stuff and throw it all
together it's not yet a living organism
that has a form or structure to it so
that's a problem from Aristotle's point
of view another problem that some of
these thinkers like an exaggerated and
pet achlys will address is that you need
some sort of other cause for explaining
why there is motion or change why did
things go the way that they did we know
that we can take matter and whatever the
matter happens to be it can it can be
take different forms or have different
qualities by configuring it in certain
ways what configures it in that way it's
not going to do it just by itself as
Aristotle says he says um if it is
really true that all generation and
destruction is out of some one entity or
even more than one why does that happen
and what is the cause it's surely not
the substrate at
self which causes itself to change
that's the problem the substrate doesn't
produce its own change or motion so he
says what I mean is that neither wood
nor bronze is responsible for changing
itself Wood does not become a bed nor
bronze a statue but something else is
the cause of the change and we can say
this even with things that are not
human-made artifacts but other types of
bodies that we encounter living beings
for example they they're going to be
affected by something that brings about
the change they may have their
principles of motion to some degree
within themselves but some of it will
also be caused from the outside and we
need to explain that the other thing
that he says that's that's important
here is that these accounts that say
that everything is is one substance or
even just a set of substances they're
kind of implausible and they they seem
rather arbitrary why should it be fire
why should it be water why should it be
this why should it be that this doesn't
provide a full intelligibility to us for
the individual things and the the cosmos
as a whole and that's part of what
metaphysics really ought to supply in
Aristotle's view so these accounts that
are based on material causes whether
they're you know you might say proto
scientific or whether they're
mythological they're really not going to
cut it and the problem is from
Aristotle's perspective they're not
recognizing the importance and the
contribution of the other three causes
you